this morning ceremony in Portsmouth
England is the last stop on president
Trump state visit to Britain before
leaving the president tried to clear up
a comment that overshadowed the start of
his trip Paula Reid is traveling with
the president in Portsmouth Paula what
else do we expect from the president
this morning
[Music]
Anthony veterans and their families tell
me they don't know quite what to expect
today but they hope that the focus today
will shift from President Trump to the
shared sacrifices made 75 years ago when
thousands of troops sailed from this
Harbor to the beaches of Normandy the
past two days of president Trump's UK
state visit have been filled with royal
pageantry protests and politics but on
the eve of the 75th anniversary of d-day
President Trump continued to try to
clear up any insults he may have made
about his royal hosts during a British
television interview do you think Megan
Michaels nasty well no no you know the
question was asked to me and I didn't
know that she said anything bad about me
it sounds like she did and that's okay I
mean they joined the crowd right the
president was referring to his
description of the Duchess of Sussex
after he was told Markel had called him
misogynistic during an interview with
the son she said she moved to Canada if
you got elected no I didn't know that
she was nasty I was referring to her
she's nice I said she was nasty about me
and essentially I didn't know she was
nasty about me ahead of today's
ceremonies the president was asked
whether he wished he could have served
in the Vietnam War a draft he avoided
due to bone spurs I would not have
minded that at all I would have been
honored but I think I make up for it
right now
and I think I'm making up for it rapidly
because we're rebuilding our military at
a level that it's never seen before the
president was also pressed on his
decision to ban transgender people from
serving in the US military blaming it on
the cost of medication they take massive
amounts of drugs they have to and also
and you're not allowed to take drugs
given the military you're not allowed to
take any drugs or the cost of the
medication is minuscule compared to you
the u.s. cemetery spends a lot more
money for example on giving viagra you
serve this men and women all I didn't
know it does that answer the president
just gave directly contradicts what the
Department of Defense said back in
twenty sixteen when it first announced
that transgender people could serve
openly in the military at the time it
cited a study that had been commissioned
that found little or no impact on unit
cohesion operational effectiveness or
readiness it also found found the cost
of gender transition related health care
costs were relatively low Anthony
Paula Reed in Portsmouth England Thank
You Paula CBS News will bring you full
coverage of tomorrow morning ceremony
here in Normandy recognizing the 75th
anniversary of d-day our special report
will begin around 5 a.m. Eastern time
for central here on CBS